clie une stratégie globale de l'union
européenne pour mettre en place un plan
de relance des états pourquoi pas nous
sommes un marché de 500 millions
d'habitants j'étais favorable qu'on
décide d'avoir un emprunt commun
remboursables individuellement en
fonction de ce que de ce que l'on
consomme
pourquoi pas or c'est parce que vous les
manuels macron emmanuel macron lui a
plaidé pour des subventions non
remboursables
individuellement c'est à dire ce ne sont
pas les pays qui rembourse et en ma
crainte et laissez-les la voyez ils se
sont mis d'accord pour emprunter ils se
sont mis d'accord pour dépenser
j'ai vu le présent la république venir
hier soir au 20 heures de tf1 et je n'ai
pas compris comme d'ailleurs je pense
tous les français comment il allait
rembourser alors il nous parle de taxe
ils nous disent et les grandes
entreprises qui vont rembourser qui mais
qui mais qui va rembourser nos
frontières il pourrait y avoir une taxe
sur le plastique alors ils pourraient
salah dessus les femmes en moi ce que
moi ce que je trouve irresponsable c'est
le flou qui était qui et dans cet accord
concernant les remboursements
quand on fait des emprunts quand on fait
des subventions sur les générations
futures
on doit être aussi responsable par
rapport aux modalités de remboursement
l'occasio croyais pas mes mots mes
annoncé la chaîne je vais juste me
sépare toujours là je pense aux
générations futures boyer j'ai des
enfants des petits enfants
je pense à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
et qui ont aussi d'aider des enfants des
petits enfants quand vous empruntez je
vous signale quand même que le délai de
remboursement court jusqu'en 2058 vous
me direz j'aurai encore passe en temps
mais quand même il faut quand même pas
exagérer comment rembourse moi je veux
bien qu'on preuve qu'on propose un plan
j'entends qu'on explique les modalités
de remboursement vous espère la
responsabilité